[Music]
martha stewart
the jailbird that criminal the criminal
is on the hunt for love oh she's on the
hunt
wants to give it to her real good isn't
that snoop dogg oh snoop dogg was
beating up for a while yeah he was yeah
they were smoking beating we're smoking
weed and [ __ ] each other and baking
cookies together they were she he was
taking it from the back and apparently
she was giving it to him pretty good too
we're like writing them on top but
didn't last it didn't last martha got it
like that i don't know
she does um
so she has she
uh said on a recent podcast that she
wished her friends would just die
so that she could date their husbands
yo she's such a gangster i love her
dude that's [ __ ] like evil [ __ ]
genius level i could take their husband
ever since she got uh she got arrested
you know she's she kept her straight she
could be herself yeah i know she's like
what are you gonna do send me to jail
everybody should get arrested once yeah
yeah i'm still wearing everything this
is so much more funnier because of the
persona that she's built out for so many
years this [ __ ] yeah like housewife
snl skit yeah just so [ __ ] perfect
right and then she's a bud smoking
criminal like i don't give a [ __ ] she
was also smoking when she was young too
right was she she loved her she was a
hippie like her old school [ __ ] yeah she
was smoking joints and [ __ ] bacon
cakes and [ __ ] she also robbed houses
when she was 12 years old oh [ __ ] her
cooking game was fired [ __ ] around at
all yeah and she was an asian gang she
was in the watchings i heard
she was watching yeah you ready she's
the infamous uh fair-skinned lady i
think yeah
apparently she's still connected to the
triads because she doesn't want to let
go of her past yeah her ex her name her
last name was the white weddle that's
right that's not the black one or the
white widow
no so she says she's had two mad crushes
in the last month and none of them were
on the market because she was hanging
out with her friends and like her their
husbands are tight but then she's like
oh man my friends like love their
husbands and so it's like kind of weird
so i'm going to kill them
so i'm going to hire some hitmen oh
she's like i hope that i have natural
causes
or choking deaths perhaps she's like if
only
yeah
so so she's uh she's announcing i'm
single ready to mingle for all the 80
year old dudes out there no i'm sure
there's a lot of baby you don't
love you i would [ __ ] martha stewart is
she 80 she's she's 80. would you guys
[ __ ] her 80.
can i see what she looks like yeah you
can absolutely see what she looks like
this is her at a i heart radio
uh hang no 80s too old for me are you
talking about like an emotionless just
objective question yeah yeah nothing to
do with anything yeah exactly would you
just [ __ ] on it and just suck on and all
that [ __ ] on it and suck off i'd be
capable i wouldn't have desire i mean
she looks like put together she's not a
[ __ ] walmart lady i bet she smells
like an old woman though does she not
she but if you're 90.
that guy that got him out dude she knows
how to cover it but if you're 90 you're
[ __ ] a hot young [ __ ] you know what
i take that back i take that back if
we had a bed made out of straw and a
[ __ ] wagon
and she's wearing some little house on
the prairie [ __ ] i'm down that's a very
specific kink yeah that's nice because i
want to like [ __ ] her back to the old
days
when she [ __ ] you back to the old days
you remind her of like where she came
from and i get to dress up as a chinese
rat woodworker
[Laughter]
there's martha with snoop
all right i can't say i'm into it they
make a good couple yeah they she should
just hook up with [ __ ] snoop yo she
was [ __ ] smoking hot as a youngin
yeah for sure i mean objectively
just as just as students of the world
dude she's a [ __ ] hot one whoa
oh yeah that's her you know
i'm gonna write martha stewart
[ __ ] titties for days
for days
f-o-r-d-a-y martha stewart the heavies
the happiness
and she's really beautiful the martha
stewart heavies project beautiful she
was smoking now she's young i do like
her magazine i do like her recipes i'm a
big fan of our residents they're really
good she got a great recipe i love the
recipes for our yeah
oh i love the green beans dude love the
green beans
y'all
she out here she looks like a vogue
model yeah she looks like a straight up
center folder why's she looking like
hannah's sister and [ __ ] that's
probably the
just got rude
and the sister
that's ty joe
joe is so honest i love when joe's
really long i love honestly it's a black
and white photo but for in my head she's
a redhead in there yeah i can see it you
know like it's a step by step barbarella
she looks like what the [ __ ] is her name
dad barbara walters remember barbarella
barbara no no no what the
jane uh god damn it vietnam jane uh [ __ ]
from [ __ ] everyone hates her uh from
[ __ ] um tom hanks [ __ ] that one
jane goodall jane uh foster
no no no fonda jane fonda
hey watch this watch this watch this i
think talking about gender jane fund is
a smoking is pretty hot you guys are
gonna be like yo steve green pretty good
call on that one
yo man those throwback 60s girls [ __ ]
all natural
yeah those woodstock chicks wow
dirty covered in mud
not bad
that's jane fonda barbarella did i nail
it or what that's what it's a smoke show
bro i don't know barbarella is a classic
like old sci-fi movie with this smokey
smoke show i like old james is she a
science project right there uh yeah kind
of no kind of she almost looks like a
young christina applegate there yeah
kind of yeah for sure but yeah no and
you know young christina applegate was
pretty pretty interesting too
um but no barbarella was like this like
she was a sex symbol because of this
movie
and then uh you know she looks very
similar i guess to hannah's sister so
there you go
all these white girls looking like
hannah's sister yeah
so we're excited for the wedding joe
because uh i guess we'll get to meet
hannah's sister there
and you're gonna wish that they were
single you're gonna wish that their
husbands died she's not single
i mean if she can wish that the husbands
die yeah yeah we can do the two or she
doesn't watch the husband's dad she was
but you get it yeah you get with the
parallels yeah do you think that's her
like just
trying to manifest a man out there just
putting it out to the universe like i am
ready to [ __ ] date
you know saying it out loud and [ __ ]
well she's never been like romantically
linked to anybody that i'm aware of
that's true she's never had a public
relationship i don't know she's always
been getting mad dick maybe because she
looks so hot like and throughout
throughout like notorious for getting
mad like throughout life she just she
always had a surplus of dick until as of
late you know what i mean like she had a
[ __ ] steward yeah she always does she
have a list the champ
martha stewart dick let's go ahead dude
i'm good this is my personal computer
hugh grant had martha stewart she had a
[ __ ] dick distribution network dude
grant was beating it the [ __ ] up for a
while yeah yeah and so that's why she
never had a [ __ ] be like yo i'm
dating because she had plenty of options
and so she was just too covered in dick
to actually step down and go wait wait a
minute i need some dick in my life she
never had that moment ever she was
always she actually coined the phrase
dick appointment yeah that's what she
got real fast that was like her thing
she goes wait i gotta get to my dick
appointments i got this oh can you call
my [ __ ] dick manager because god damn
i got too much dick today did you guys
know that martha stewart um has recently
released a frozen food um um
menagerie like a microwavable line yeah
i love frozen i love her products is she
gonna compete with marie calendars and
[ __ ] now that's what she's trying to do
she's calling martha calendars that's
her play
but no she really does have like a bunch
of frozen food is it good i don't
[ __ ] know you just saw it at that i
saw it was google i heard the wolfgang
puck frozen pizzas are [ __ ] good
i've never tried them but i keep hearing
that i'll be so honest i've only had
good frozen pizza i think frozen pizza
is incredible oh actually uh [ __ ]
some of those like some of the celeste
pizzas are kind of gross so this piece
is awful but digiorno is good jordan's
eye is pretty [ __ ] good giorno is
above jordan is pretty good and they can
[ __ ] off about it yeah dude remember you
brought those
pizza to
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is going on i was just
talking to people i didn't really pay
attention to the oven
i should have didn't set a timer but
that's fine that was a good time it was
really fun but yeah apparently plastic
melts big time in the oven apparently
you're supposed to remove before cooking
by the way you should take the digiorno
out of the box before you cook it good
place to start we just trusted you in
the kitchen but it didn't say it on the
label which is why he does it i'm a
millionaire
i'm gonna go get a red baron after this
man like baron's fire too red baron
supreme is not even don't even [ __ ]
around with it it's good
you put it in your mouth
is good too cbc frozen pizza is good
the barbecue chicken pizza
it's hard to mess up frozen have you
guys ever tried the difference between
ordering pizza hut
on postmates and pizza hut on the app no
what's that i thought pizza doesn't come
on postmates only bart would try it yeah
there's a huge difference this is rich
guy stuff so this is what i learned
right we keep getting these pizzas that
are [ __ ] lukewarm
and it's because it's these goddamn
[ __ ]
separate contractors ordering i mean
send me the pizza the pizza box thing
yeah when you order directly through the
app the delivery person is qualified
certified pizza pizza hut personnel dude
that comes with the whole velcro thing
do you order dominoes through postmates
too yes and don't ever do that and it's
just smoking
yeah it's smoking hot
it was like i missed the feeling of like
you open it oh [ __ ]
i missed that this is why you go to
little caesars and you get the hot and
ready dude yeah but then he's gonna go
somewhere no we can't he's not leaving
his face yeah i want it to come and then
i just open and eat it no let me tell
you something bart cause cause you're
gonna burn your fingertips that's what i
want i got a little seizures i get the
hot and ready i have to put on gloves
because it's so cold i'm like i'm like
oh it's cold
you can use it as ice cubes for your
drink oh
right but hey it's ready
that's what it is that's it hey
it's ready there's one of two qualifying
things for this for this pizza it's hot
and it's ready can't blame any driver
for that yup can't blame some [ __ ]
app no that's how the app's the best
that's ridiculous that you ordered
domino's i know i never even thought of
that because i'm like why don't you just
go to the site today because it's
postmates you know they deliver because
postmates is my food person so i order
everything mexican italian chinese
whatever i order it through that person
but then now i'm like exceptional you
see that's problem you forsake your
relationship that you have a pizza
before posting because they were they
were the original postmates dude bart is
ordering from the bacchanal buffet
the circus circus buffet on postmates
each individual item's showing up colder
and colder and colder and bart's like
this is whack yeah
i got to stop doing this i tried to go
to the buffet instead
of soft serve too do they understand why
it came [ __ ]
amen some people got the freezer cooler
stuff and it keeps it nice and cold but
what does anything have to do with
martha stewart being a hottie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you